BEN HARRIS: Hi,
and welcome back.
Today we're going to do
a problem about the four
fundamental subspaces.
So here we have a
matrix B. B is written
as the product of a
lower triangular matrix
and an upper triangular matrix.
And we're going to find
a basis for, and compute
the dimension of,
each of the four
fundamental subspaces of B.
I'll give you a minute to try
that on your own, to hit pause,
and then I'll be right
back in just a minute
and we can do it together.
OK.
We're back.
Now, the first
thing to notice is
that this is an LU
decomposition of B.
So we have L here and U here.
Now let's go one
space at a time.
Let's start with
the column space.
And first, let's just say what
the dimension of the column
space is.
OK, so let's look
at our U matrix.
How many pivots do we have?
We have two pivots, so the
column space has dimension 2.
This is the number of pivots.
Good.
Now, how do we find a
basis for the column space?
How do we find that basis?
Well, in lecture,
Professor Strang
had started with a matrix
B. He did elimination on it,
and then he took the pivot
columns in the original matrix.
And that's great.
That works.
You can also take the pivot
columns in the L matrix.
You can see by multiplying
this out that it will amount
to essentially the same thing.
So a basis for
this column space,
I can just take these two
pivot columns of my L matrix,
[1, 2, -1] and [0, 1, 0].
Good.
OK.
So there's the dimension
of and the basis
for the column space of B.
Next, let's do the
null space together.
OK.
What's the dimension
of the null space?
Well, the dimension
of the null space
is always the number of columns
minus the number of pivots.
Right?
It's the number
of free variables.
So here, that's just one.
Good.
And how do we find this one
vector in the null space?
Well, what we do
is we can just plug
in 1 for our free
variable, and we can
backsolve to get the other two.
So this equation tells me
that my second number is -1,
and this equation tells me
that that third variable -3/5,
if I can fit it in here.
That's a -3/5, if it's difficult
to see that on the tape.
Now, let's move on,
next, to the row space.
Next is the row space.
So how do we find the
dimension of the row space?
I'm going to write row space
as column space of B transpose.
How do we find that?
Well, remember that one of
our big facts in this class
is that the dimension
of the row space
is the same as the dimension
of the column space.
It's just the number of pivots.
So that's good.
It's 2.
And how do we find a
basis for the row space?
There are a couple ways
of thinking about this.
One way to think about it is:
we got this upper triangular
matrix from B by
doing elimination.
And elimination doesn't
change the row space.
So I can just use the two
pivot rows of the matrix U.
Basis for my row
space here is: I just
put these two pivot
rows together,
and I get a basis
for this row space.
The last one is always the
toughest and the trickiest.
We have to do the left null
space or the null space of B
transpose.
First, let's compute
its dimension.
What's the dimension of
this left null space?
Well, there's a similar
formula to the one
we used when we were
computing the dimension
of the null space.
It's just the number of rows
minus the number of pivots.
So there are three rows.
Our matrix is 3 by 3.
And there are two pivots.
So this is just
one-dimensional, again.
We need to compute, now,
this left null space.
Let me go back to
our original matrix.
The way to do this is to take
B equals L*U, and invert L,
and get E*B equals U. So we need
to move L over to the left-hand
side.
If we do that-- I'm just
going to write that down here.
So what's the inverse
of the L matrix?
We just get 1, -2,
1, 0, 1, 1, times B,
is our U matrix, this
upper triangular matrix.
Now that I moved L
over to the other side,
I can read off the vectors
in my left null space.
Now, I'm looking at
not my pivot variables
but my free variables, because
it's some sort of null space.
but I want to look
at this E matrix.
So the third row of this
E matrix, the third row
corresponds to
the three row here
and when I multiply this
by B, I just get zeros,
so this is in the
left null space.
A basis for this
left null space is--
see if I can fit it here--
just this [1, 0, 1].
Good.
So we've found the dimension of
and basis for all of the four
fundamental subspaces.
Before I move on, I
just want to recall
which of the L matrix
or the U matrix
we used for each
of these subspaces.
So for the column space,
we used the pivot columns
of the L matrix.
For the null space, we
looked at the U matrix.
For the row space, we also
And for the left null space, we
needed to invert the L matrix
and look at the free row.
We're done with the problem.
But the last thing
that's useful is
to draw a picture,
which I have right here.
I know in lecture
Professor Strang
has drawn you some sort of
cartoon pictures of what
these subspaces look like.
But here I want to try
to actually draw them
in a special case.
So if you can read my drawing
here, what do we have?
We have the row space here,
and the null space here.
Right?
And so B maps this
picture into this picture.
The null space here--
all the scalar multiples
of this vector-- all go
to 0, because they're
in the null space.
That's exactly
what B takes to 0.
B takes everything else,
including the row space,
into this column space.
And what does B transpose do?
Well, B transpose kills
this left null space,
kills this vector,
and it take everything
else into the row
space, into the column
space of B transpose.
OK.
Thanks for doing this
exercise together.
I hope this picture is helpful.